[موسيقى]
الاعلام الاوكرانيه ترفع من جديد فوق ارض
المدينه خرسون جنوب شرقي البلاد
فالمقاطعه التي دخلها الجيش الروسي بدايه
مارس الماضي وضمتها موسكو بشكل رسميا
الاراضيها قبل نحو شهر ونصف اصبح مركزها
في الضفه الغربيه لنهر دنيرو تحت السيطره
الكامله للجيش الاوكراني ورغم اعلان وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه اكتمال نقل قواتها الى
الضفه الشرقيه للنهار دون ان تتكبد اي
خسائر فان الكرم على التاكيد انه لم يطرق
اي تغيير على موقف موسكو باعتبار مقاطعه
خرسون جزءا من الاراضي الروسيه ما اثار
مزيدا من التساؤلات بشان ملابسات الانسحاب
الروسي من هناك وما الذي دفع موسكو لتتحمل
مخاطر نقل اكثر من 30,000 جندي ونحو خمسه
الاف من الوحدات والمعدات العسكريه وسط
المعارك الى الضفه الاخرى من النهر اذا
كانت قال له تعتبر خرصون مقاطعه روسيه على
ان اللافته ايضا هو ذلك التزامن بين
استكمال الانسحاب الروسي وحصول انهيارات
في جسر انتنوفو كخوفكا على نهر دني برو
وهم الجسران الوحيدان اللذان يربطان بين
ضفتين النهر ويصلان جانبي خرسان ببعضهما
لكل طرف روايته بشان اسباب الانهيارات
الجيش الروسي يقول انها حصلت اثناء تبادل
للقصف مع الجيش الاوكراني خلال الانسحاب
وكييف تقول ان الروس تعمد استهداف الجسرين
واين تكون الروايه الادب فان الثابته هنا
ان ذلك التدمير سيجعل من امكانيه عوده
الجيش الروسي بعتاده الثقيل الى خرسان
امرا صعبا كما سيعرقل الجيش الاوكراني عن
مواصله تقدمه نحو باقي مناطق المقاطعه
الجنوبيه
المتاخمه لشبه جزيره القرم ما يجعل
الاستهداف القوات سيه في القرن من البر
امرا صعب المنال بالعتاد المتوفر